first off a lion swimming in the ocean
lions don't like water if you place it
near a river or some sort of fresh water
source that makes sense but you find
yourself in the ocean 20-foot waves I'm
assuming it's off the coast of South
Africa coming up against a full-grown
800-pound tuna with his 20 or 30 friends
you lose that battle you lose that
battle nine times out of ten don't be
fooled by the first class suit in a big
house three Spellman's nothing more than
a two-bit drug dealer you want some
proof here's some proof
it's a bad man this is what bad men do
happy Bar Mitzvah baby I love you no
wait I'm not kidding anymore I can't
lift a month watchman I can't lift him
lift Meyer sir
just tuck your head and relax your body
breathe do it you know what they give
you for that the gas chamber
you know what the gas chamber smells
like finally that's where you headed boy
to a pine oil heaven I'm gonna get that
gun and then I'm gonna get that money I
don't believe you got it in you Jake
I'm gonna go get it right now are you
muggle next one will kill you Oh son of
a [ __ ]
now drop him
you're a doctor
deal with it yeah mother leave her
someplace just sell her out
tell me where she is white o16 where the
girl white I have this under control
here's the girl what semester no no
novel on Crown Court House upstairs
god damn this picture with dated three
days ago
look it's dated exactly one year ago
today got a hair sample I got a stool
sample I got piss I got fingernail it's
laughing at us yeah I'm supposed to tell
you you're breaking in a new partner in
on this partner yeah yeah some K he's on
loan from dope real burnout on the
ragged edge Oh perfect God Raj meet your
new partner
and to offer this
you